[Musique]
ça a commencé quand
ma mère est morte sans elle j'ai commencé à
m'évanouir comment personne ne
pouvait me réveiller  je fais semblant d'avoir
disparu
de la vue et de la mémoire
finalement tu t'adaptes je vis une
vie assez normale
j'ai un travail cette fille a un sixième sens
merci je montre aux gens comme ils sont vraiment
hé pourquoi tu suis ces gens que
tu peux voir
je '  je ne te laisse pas attendre reste
loin de moi
je ne peux pas tu es la seule personne qui peut
qui peut ce que
je suis invisible n'est ce pas j'ai besoin que tu
me crois
sorte de la rue je suis le seul gars
dans le  monde entier qui peut te voir
que suis-je censé faire avec ça je
pense que nous sommes censés nous entraider
peut-être que si je peux réparer ce que j'ai cassé les
choses reviendront à la normale pour
nous deux alors tu vas juste redémarrer mon
carrière de combattant et ensuite tu dois
me rendre avec juliana
je ne pense pas que perdre nous devons nous
améliorer v  enues de
plus gros combats comment tu peux me faire correspondre
avec de meilleurs combattants donne
-moi juste une liste j'ai quelques mouvements donc
tu combats carlos juarez
comment as-tu réussi ça avait l'air
super là-bas
je veux que tu sois la vraie fille de l'ombre
si tu '  j'essaie de me rendre jaloux ça
marche
[Musique]
shane qu'est-ce que tu faisais avec juliana
elle t'utilise houx
attends je me soucie de toi houx mais
quoi que
tu aies tu dois faire face à ce qui s'est passé
allez shane
je suis là
une fois il y avait un  fille qui était invisible
cette fille c'est moi
toi